driverless car technology is moving fast
multiple trials are taking place all
over the world but this one is different
this trial is all about getting the
views of the general public people have
no experience in this technology and who
are perhaps even a little bit
apprehensive later on today the public
will be invited to have a go but ahead
of that I've invited two people I know
and trust to give me their views hi mum
hi J my grandpa my mum and her mate are
just the sort of people the trial is
after mum's 63 year old reluctant but
regular user of computers and a nervous
driver 75 year old Guinevere is a petrol
head who doesn't own a smartphone what
do you think about the idea mum of a
computer being absolutely in charge of
everything right now don't like it why I
took my key I don't really like the idea
of it at all I don't know a computer
when VAR I know that you you like you
like your sports cars you like you like
to drive what do you think about the
idea of right now the computers in
charge ok nothing I like to be
controlled and I think I mean there's
somebody in control at the moment I
think no no no Oh what is that to drive
the other it's a computer just to
computer just behind you you where we're
just going past a pedestrian here and
what do you think about the idea that
the computer is making a walls yes I
think it's a little bit rough it's
obviously safe
I mean otherwise we wouldn't be in it
how you trust a engineer's dude like
this yes I do getting views from the
general public is the final part of this
eight million pound government-backed
project the idea is to use feedback to
help design the vehicle around its
future users and what would you do to
make the drive feel better and you feel
bit more safe
I don't feel unsafe at the moment if it
was going faster I probably want
seatbelts on because I'm used to doing
that it's all the things you used to
steering-wheel Ron hey what would you do
with it you look like one those ones you
seven years kids let's play ones with it
designers say they're ruling nothing out
and over the next three weeks
researchers will get feedback from
hundreds more guinea pigs